so what is going on with brad right's
pilot for stargate
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i just did a video guys a couple of
weeks ago about how brad wright's
initial pilot has just been put up with
storyboarding they've actually
commissioned a storyboard for his series
that he wrote nearly two years ago now
now that actually is huge it really
shows that amazon and mgm are starting
to really gear up towards the new series
being produced as soon as the amazon mgm
sale is complete
but
it does come with a few
concerns
because apparently a second pilot has
also been put forward for storyboarding
now these storyboards will take
anything up to two to three months
apparently my source is telling me and
they are actually quite an expensive
thing to commission
so you would not storyboard brad
wright's version unless you were very
seriously contemplating using it
but this second storyboard is the worry
for a couple of reasons
i have two or three people that work at
mgm that talk to me about what's going
on and they work in different
departments they're friends with each
other and they know i met one and they
put me close with the others
none of them have any idea where the
second scriptures come from
now that's a bit of a worry considering
obviously i can't tell you which
departments they work in but i know
which departments are working it seems
to me that it's purposely being kept
secret that they are even keeping a
secret from the employees at mgm they
know they don't want anyone to know
what the script is and be where the
script came from or who wrote it but why
would mgm do that well obviously brad
wright has a very strong relationship
with mgm and the people at mgm he knows
the people there he's worked with him
for years
so
he's going to have friends within the
organization
it seems to me that mgm are personally
trying to keep this secret because
they're purposely trying to keep it from
brad wright so does brad wright know
that there is some politics going on
here i actually think he does on his
podcast he's had interviews with amanda
tapping
michael shanks and richard dean anderson
he has done that artificially created
episode of stargate on there and he
talks very openly about the project and
the pilot he's already written now why
would he be doing that i think he's
doing it because he wants to get the
public opinion onto his side he wants to
make it very very difficult for mgm to
produce any other tv series but his
but mgm might be in a bit of a difficult
situation obviously they've been
restrained by financial problems for
20 years or so
they
maybe didn't think they could produce
the stargate series that they now have
the financial might to produce
and amazon have come in and said look
what you've got is great we love it but
we want you to think a lot bigger we
actually now think you can be a lot more
ambitious with this project
but brad wright's
initial pilot was written for maybe a
slightly more restrained budget so mgm
are in a bit of a difficult spot
do they
basically push brad right out
do they try to get brad right to rewrite
what he's already done and make it
bigger as amazon say or do they go with
a different project so this is what i
think they're doing
they're storyboarding brad wright's
pilot they're storyboarding another
possible version of that pilot or a
completely different script i'm not sure
either way
they're going to show them to executives
and they're going to try to get them to
decide which project they want to go
with
they'll then either work with brad
wright to
beef up and change his original plot
or they'll go with a completely
different direction
but the storyboarding of the scripts
they have in place now is vital for that
to moving forwards they need to be able
to visualize what they're talking about
and this is going to be a really
important thing to show them to amazon
executives that people are actually
going to write the check for the series
i'm also being told by my sources mgm
that big meetings are planned for very
early april
this is when these storyboards will be
presented they're also hoping that the
sale of mgm will be in its very final
days by that point so that they can
maybe start making some decisions
and decisions not just about stargate
but james bond what to do with the back
catalogue
and some other projects that are in
early development can be maybe green lit
so what i actually think is brad being
pushed out of the stargate universe
i actually think amazon are going to
want to come in and they're going to
want some fresh ideas i think they're
going to want new blood in this project
and
i actually don't think brad wright's
initial script at least how it exists at
the moment will be made
i think they're going to want something
that fits in with their idea of having a
movie that fits in with the game that's
just been about to be released
timekeepers and other projects that they
want to maybe bring online including an
ancients prequel series and other things
and i'm not sure brad wright's current
plan for series fits in with those other
projects so what do i think brad stands
at the moment
i don't think his project is going to
get made and i think he knows it and i
think that's why he is trying to get the
public opinion onto his side so that he
can add pressure to amazon to hopefully
get it made somehow so anyway guys
please leave a comment tell me what you
think is this a lot of politics going on
at the moment i will remind you that
amazon haven't actually made any
decisions yet and those decisions aren't
going to be made for several months but
planning is happening they are in talks
and what do you think those talks are
going to entail
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can also become a sidetrack member hit
that join button and please guys as
always stay safe i'll see you next time
foreign